can everybody hear me if I talk like
this louder okay good
it's easier with them without the mic
okay so thanks for having me my name is
Nicholas Christian I'm VP of product at
plotly and I'm here to talk to you about
it's a bit of an ambitious talk I only
have 20 minutes but I'm gonna try and
talk about two great open-source
libraries plotly Express and - so plotly
Express is a library we've just launched
we launched it 10 days ago I'm very
excited about it I'm the the lead author
for it and it's a library for data
visualization with a special focus on
data exploration through rapid iteration
so you've got the website right there
turns out partly that expresses a valid
domain so we got it and if you just want
to play with it it's it's a pip install
plotly Express and the other open source
library I'm going to talk to you about
it's called dash and dash is a framework
for creating analytical web applications
in pure Python so the tag line for - and
I'll sort of show you why that why that
is is no Java Script required and again
you've got the website for - right there
and just a quick note both of these
libraries or MS MIT license they're
totally free for any purpose Polly has a
couple of commercial products but I
won't talk about them tonight so
everything I'm showing you today you can
do yourself at home or on your laptop
right now if you like so quick show of
hands though before I get started who
here uses Python mostly for data science
mostly for web development all right and
if you had to make a chart right now in
Python you would use matplotlib raw
matplotlib Seabourn bouquet plotly okay
couple values and the web developers
among you guys using Django or flask
okay so it's not my intention
necessarily to replace either of those
libraries as part of your daily toolkit
but but certainly I'm hoping to entice
you a little bit in both of these so but
most of my talk will just basically be
some live demos
hopefully so partly Express is most
useful from a Jupiter notebook and it's
intended to be as easy and simple to use
as possible so I'm going to kind of
create a bit of a role-playing scenario
here let's pretend that I'm a data
scientist it's 9:00 a.m. I've gotten a
new a new data set that I don't know
much about I'm gonna fire up plotly
Express and see if I can make any sense
of it so cloudy Express is pretty easy
you just import it and the data set I'm
going to use is the tips data set it's
actually built into plotly Express for
demo purposes and it's pretty simple
it's pretty small 244 rows each row
represent a restaurant bill you've got
some columns there you've got some
categorical columns some numerical
columns so basically the total tip so
total total bill the tip sex is the sex
of the payer smoker is whether there
were any smokers in the party the entire
more obvious and then the size is the
size of the party so here's the data set
it's kind of interesting and you know
I'm gonna sort of working data scientist
I'm gonna explore so you see what's
going on with with plotly Express so
let's make a basic scatter plot the X
dot scatter
I'll give it my data and let's take a
look at total bill versus tips so one
lines pretty much pretty much what do
you expect you know you does what it
says on the box scatter x equals total
bill y equals tab a couple of couple of
things to note this is a fully
interactive plot so you have you have
hovers you can you can pan you can zoom
and it's set up you know the axes for
you which is kind of nice but let's see
let's see if we can dig into this this
data side a little bit it's kind of hard
to see what the distribution is here
let's do some margin rules here so
marginal x equals box marginal y equals
violin okay so now i've got sort of a
marginal plot here of i'll in plot a box
plot with an aw
some outliers kind of interesting some
of the other columns I've got here sex
let's take a look at that so color equal
sex
all right starting to split the data for
me so the basic principles are partly
Express are just that you give it a data
frame and then whatever visual variable
you care about like the x position the Y
position or the color you just tell it
the name of the data frame sorry the
name of the column and it sort of
handles the rest for you it signs colors
it creates the legend and everything's
nice and interactive everything's
cross-linked here so I can pan it pans I
double click to reset I click to hide a
series I click to show a series
everything sort of works out as you'd
expect and I can keep going let's say
I'm interested in in seeing if there's
any kind of trend in these here so yeah
ok women in men when they pay they tip
at approximately the same rate these
trend lines are roughly the same slope
you can mouse over here it shows you the
trend line it shows you the equation it
computes the r-squared for you the kind
of basic stuff you'd expect from from
data data visualization library but
there's some other columns in this data
set so let's let's take a look so
instead of these marginals here let's
let's look at some other variables like
whether or not there were any smokers so
now I've I faceted my data so whether
your data is on one or more subplots
from the point of view of plot Lee
Express is just like whether your data
is blue or red it's just another visual
variable and you shouldn't do a big song
and dance about declaring subplots and
knowing how many you have and creating
all the titles and stuff koala Express
just kind of does that for you and so
here you can see non-smokers on the on
the right austere on the Left smokers on
the right a slightly different slope on
the trend lines there mmm r-squared
isn't very good probably not a very
strong relationship but maybe maybe
worth digging into alright but I see
that there's some some other columns
here in the data set like de let's take
a look maybe I can pass it again by day
yeah a little bit messy maybe instead of
coloring by vice maybe I can not color
or not add some trend lines here okay
facet by let's do de this way time this
way how interesting
so first of all a couple things to note
here I've got my days kind of out of
order this is pretty common with data
visualization libraries it's kind of a
pain so plow Express has some built-in
built-in functionality for avoiding this
problem you can basically tell it day
look this is the order I want alright
this is the order I want it in and then
lunch and dinner you can see that
actually interestingly enough only one
person in this data set had dinner on
Thursday maybe we should close the
restaurant on Thursday afternoons it'd
be it would it would save us also money
so you can see that it's fairly easy to
kind of very rapidly slice and dice your
data just by one function call in plotly
Express now we do more than just scatter
plots let's take a look at you know now
that I'm looking at my data by by day
I'm interested in how much money am I
actually making well let's take a look
here I can do a bar chart x equals day y
equals total bill all right are the
orders out of whack again so I could
just probably just copy the same the
same thing here so you notice that the
arguments to bar and scatter are
basically the same kind of kind of nice
and it's it's everything every row in my
data set here is a little rectangle just
like every row in my data said in the
previous plot was was a color so Polly
Express comes with a whole bunch of
different plotting functions out of the
box you know it's not a competition but
who has the most chart types but you've
got bars you've got scatters I can do
maps I have a couple examples of that
sort of thing for you a little bit later
line charts some interesting
multi-dimensional multi-dimensional
types like scatter matrix is actually
really cool you can basically see every
variable plotted against every other
variable and when you do a selection
they kind of like does a cross linked
selection across them
and you can sort of pan and zoom one
function call ladies and gentlemen
scatter matrix so this is partly Express
I don't have time to go into a full
detailed tutorial but I just wanna kind
of give you a taste of the kind of data
exploration you can do just with one
library a couple of simple function
calls in a Jupiter notebook so that's my
morning as a data scientist but in the
afternoon I need to communicate my
results with other people in my company
this very thriving restaurant business
with my 244 meals per week you know I
need to communicate these findings with
with the other waiters on staff the
problem is they don't use Jupiter
notebooks and they don't want to type
Python code I'm the only I'm the only
Python nerd in the group so I would be
stuck except that there is plot leas -
library so - is a framework that allows
you to very easily build web
applications in pure Python
I don't know JavaScript I'm just enough
of a nerd to know Python that's about it
but I do I do want to share my my cool
charts with my colleagues so how am I
gonna do well I'm gonna build a - app
and actually I'm in a live coda - app
for you so this is a basic - app you
just import the - package and some HTML
components you create an app and then
you give it what's called a layout so
here if anybody here knows HTML I said
no JavaScript required right - you got
to know a little bit of HTML - to get a
- outgoing I basically got two headers
you know demo plotly Express in - and
then h2 is just I'm a sub header and
then I run my server so second to think
about it pick up the tab alright
hopefully that's clear enough so fairly
simple this is not really an app so far
but you know I can I can lay out the
frame of a web server web page and and I
can serve it so it wouldn't be an app
unless there was some interactivity so
I'll show you how you can set up some
interactivity in pure Python this is a
0pi here's my first example so here
things have gotten a little bit more
complicated I mean
boarding - core components as DCC
there's some sort of interactive
dropdowns and that sort of thing
and some inputs and some outputs my
layout has changed a little bit I've now
got an input with idx and and my my
level 2 header here and I was called X
out and I'm declaring a simple function
which I'm decorating with app call back
and I'm saying the children property of
X dot out depends on the value property
of X and the relationship is just X so
let's see let's see what happens when I
run this app I save it the app should
reboot and it will be load ok so now
I've got my input field here and I can
type ok so what's happening under the
hood here well if I look at my network
tab every time I type any time sorry any
time I type up here you see some in case
you see some post requests happening so
basically the web browser is making a
bunch of calls to my Python app which is
essentially just returning x over and
over and over so I'm essentially able to
build a reactive application that
includes some dynamic components on the
front end but without writing any
JavaScript which is kind of neat ok so
let's move a little bit beyond inputs
and text here and and get to some charts
so in the second example I'm going to
load up partly express the tips data set
again and I'll grab all the the names of
the columns and instead of an input oops
I'm going to use a drop-down and the
options will basically be all of the
different columns of my data frame and
then instead of an h2 I'm gonna have a
graph and the figure is basically going
to be a scatter plot so I'm gonna
initialize it to an empty scatter plot
just so it looks nice and my callback is
now basically saying that the figure
property of my graph is going to just be
the output of a plot Lee Express call
let's see what happens
all right so here's my here's my
scatterplot here's my drop-down I can
now put tip total bill as I as I move
the drop-down HTTP calls are happening
to my app in the background and I can
see the new chart being populated okay
this is not that interesting to see just
the x-axis because actually the y-axis
here is just kind of the order of the
data so let's get on to sort of the next
level here where I want to actually be
able to control X Y color fascicle and
facet row instead of one drop down here
I'm gonna have a list of them so a whole
bunch of different drop downs and then
my callback is gonna have a bunch of
different inputs but it's still just
basically going to be the same I'm just
gonna map these things straight into two
plotly Express
help it along a little bit so here I've
got you know X total bill Y is gonna be
tip color is gonna be sex fascicle is
gonna be smoker and fast that row is
gonna be day alright so now I've
basically built a little web application
that I can just host on my laptop I can
upload to Heroku I can host like any
other web application this is all built
on flask by the way so it's just a flask
application that I can host anywhere and
instead of giving my findings to my
colleagues as they do put a note book
and having them code Python I just send
them a link to this application and they
can kind of poke around with these with
these dropdowns
this isn't all you can do with - but
it's kind of a neat example of how easy
it is to hook up some front-end input
elements to some charts in 30 lines of
Python plus a couple new lines so that's
kind of exciting it's a little bit ugly
though so let's let's just style it a
little bit I just added a couple little
little style style elements just to show
that it's not all all Times New Roman so
there we go it's like a slightly nicer
version of this thing colored by smoker
split by time and day and there you go
fairly easy to share my findings
you know insightful as they might be
with my colleagues using - so that's
kind of a lightning tour through through
- and plotly Express so drilling in a
little bit on in terms of what we can do
partly Express is basically a wrapper
around plotly pie which is partly sort
of fairly mature battle-tested
I did a visualization library but it
kind of hides all the details for you so
some of the charts I made in just one
line here one function call they take 10
20 30 lines of Python our documentation
to make so partly Express allows you to
be significantly more efficient about
sort of thinking about the graph that
you want and not sort of thinking about
the data structures that you need to
build in order to feed to plot Li to get
the graph that you want so you can stay
kind of at the data and I did an
analytic level of your thinking plot
Express supports all sorts of different
chart types beyond beyond the ones I was
able to kind of live code for you here
today so 2d 3d polar
chards turnery charts we've got maps of
a few different kinds built-in
animations faceting you've seen trend
lines and marginals just kind of
exciting and it inherits a whole bunch
of cool features from it's a big brother
of plot Levi so you can export to any
format PNG SVG PDF offline HTML you can
export it to the underlying JSON
representation we have a free and open
source GUI editor which you can use to
edit all the different different aspects
of your figures and we have built in and
user-defined themes and so close your
eyes if you're epileptic all of these
charts are just one line with platypi so
some 3d polar lines polar bars with the
dark theme slippy maps lines on a map
animated choropleth scatter plot matrix
parallel coordinates parallel sets
contours all this and more is built into
two plotly Express and therefore it's
accessible from dash basically just
directly and just like plotly Express is
more than just what I've shown you - is
a bit more than what I've shown you so I
basically showed you one chart five
dropdowns here are a few more
complicated examples this is one that
we've made which I've actually already
got loaded so this is basically
exploring support vector machines with a
bunch of different parameters and it
shows you know you've got kind of a
funky chart here that shows the output
of a machine learning model and some
random data you can change the data set
you can change the sample size you can
play with the threshold of your machine
learning model here you can see inputs
that depend on each other so radial
basis function has no degree but a
polynomial does so you can see that the
inputs can kind of depend on each other
everything refreshes fairly fast this
things up in the cloud so even though
it's making sort of big HTTP calls every
time you change one of the inputs to get
the graph back still very very quick and
very very easy to build an app like this
so the the source for this is up on
github you have to scroll a little bit I
don't know why but if you scroll here
you got the link for the this app so
this is one that we've made but what
we're most excited about it plotly is
that people are actually using - sort of
out in the wild as any sort of
successful open source project and so
what we've seen is that there's a couple
of papers that have come out in nature
recently
we're sort of actual hardcore scientists
are using - to present the results to
each other which is hugely exciting for
us so this is an example of the website
to support a paper entirely built in -
so this isn't just a little app right
this is the entire site is in - you've
got sort of a tab navigation up here a
user guide we were super impressed when
when this when this app came out this
person really just grabbed - and sort of
used it for all it was worth to present
their results
I don't really know about I really know
a whole lot about about gene editing but
you know I know I know a sexy data app
when I see one
so this person has has gone has gone
sort of all in on on - and is using this
to present their results which is really
exciting for us and there's another app
that came sorry another paper that came
out recently in nature talking about the
cost of electricity in sub-saharan
Africa and here they're using again a
lot of features of both plot it up plot
Lina PI this is pre plot Lee Express and
- to build some some fairly
sophisticated models these ones a little
less reactive because I think they
actually need to execute some
complicated come on the background so
they have like an update button so it's
a little bit less reactive but just goes
to show some of the sort of flexibility
and power of of - as a sort of an
application framework and of plotly dot
PI as a visualization framework to back
it and so we're very excited to sort of
give these two libraries away to the
community to see what kind of apps
people can build out of - to see what
kind of charts people can build and I
plot Lee Express and we work very hard
to make sure that they sort of clicked
together very nicely so that one lets
you use the other as smoothly as
possible I have time for a couple of
questions if people have any questions
yep
it really depends on the details of what
you're doing
certainly at some point you will run
into latency issues there are a couple
of different ways to sorry the question
was for those who can't hear at what
point do you write into latency issues
when you have large data sets it depends
a little bit on whether this is an app
that sort of hosted on the on the public
internet or whether it's hosted inside
your network but it's definitely one of
the engineering considerations you need
to take into account when building a -
app overall though I have personally
been surprised at how not much of a
problem it is it sort of turns out to
work out pretty well most of the time
and there are a couple of different ways
that are coming out I think this week to
move some of the processing to the
client side by writing a little bit of
JavaScript if you need to so they're
sort of the client-side escape hatch for
for faster processing but the general
recommendation that we have is sort of
build it the naive way you might be
surprised if it turns out to be a real
problem there are there are ways of
optimizing things
adding for example gives you sort of
selectors that comes directly from that
but let's say I have my own selection
just with my CSS can i plug in in - yes
absolutely the way that each of these is
a component so - core components is a
component library and we have a sort of
fairly mechanical way of wrapping react
components connecting them into the -
framework and making them available and
so there are a number of third-party
components that have been built we have
a couple of libraries we have - bio and
- DAC which are a couple of different
widget toolkits that you can use for
different applications if you have a
particular chart type that you like or a
particular calendar picker or very
complex control in JavaScript
in order to make access make it
accessible to - you have to first wrap
it and react and then and then - and
that's if you go to - stop plot ly
there's a component builders guide that
kind of walks you through the details of
that the great thing is once you've done
that if you open-source it it's
available to all - users in the
community and so we're always very
excited when people contribute sort of
new components - the - the - community
and make them available to each other ok
well I'll be around during the break if
anybody has any questions that they
don't feel comfortable shouting out
thank you for listening
[Applause]